good evening my name is Bill kroyer I am
one of the governors of the short films
and feature animation branch of the
academy and i'd like to welcome you to
this night honoring the medium that is
the most successful most honored media
mala film the animated feature film i
could say that because in Snow White
came out of 1939 minute per minute
animated feature films have made more
money sold more tickets and I think
inspired more people than any other
medium and the nominees this year I
think we'll carry on that tradition so
our branch animation short films and
future animation we actually have two
nights that we honor our nominees one of
the few branches that does that tonight
we automate our animate honor our
animated feature guys and on Tuesday
night we on honored our short film
nominees and I'm proud to say that those
two nights sell out faster than any
other events the entire Academy calendar
so thank you very much for making that
happen thank you for your enthusiasm for
doing that give yourselves a round of
applause for that
last night we had a terrific thing it
for the first time ever we had this
night that they just invented it was
called the branch nominees dinner and we
had just the nominees from the short
films in the animation and the governors
and a couple of guests who got together
had dinner had a few drinks told war
stories it was really really a special
night you know I just think we have such
a special branch you know in short films
the live-action film making can be so
big and complex in political short films
the filmmakers actually make the films
you know when you meet these people they
made the films and it's the same way
with our animation directors tonight you
know you're on the community a lot of
you you know you've worked with these
people we've come up to the trenches
with them we know them they're real
filmmakers I am just so proud so proud
to be part of this wonderful branch and
these terrific these terrific nominees
so this is a big year for animated
features we had the most qualified
features ever in the history of the word
this is the 12th year we've had the
animation feature award the past 11
statues have gone to some of the
greatest directors have ever worked in
animated features Miyazaki bird stanton
park and on sunday night one of these
names tonight will join that list but
tonight as we like to say everybody is a
winner because tonight everybody has
that monica that they will have for the
rest of their lives Academy Award
nominee
it's a really special night and we have
a really special host you know we're
just setting all kinds of new standards
here at the academy this is the first
time we've ever had a United States
Marine lieutenant colonel host the
Animated Feature today he's a really
talented actor you've seen him on
television I've seen him in the movies
you've heard his voice and animated
features despite his busy schedule he
helps returning veterans get a start in
Hollywood he's a really funny and
terrific guy please give a warm round of
applause to our host tonight mr. Rob
Riggle
alright this is gonna be a fun night oh
well welcome good evening we're gonna
have fun tonight it's great opportunity
right to to meet some of the some of the
finest directors working in film today
am i right yeah so this will be good
this would be good we'll get to spend
time with them ask him some questions
I'm not going to stand up here and go
off for long so we can get right to the
meat of it I got to tell you though I
got to be honest when my wife told me
that the Academy was on the phone I kind
of lost it started screaming all kinds
of things mainly I told you so of course
I ran outside before she could stop me
and I told most of the neighborhood to
kiss my ass also set them other things
like I'm untouchable and above the law
and it kind of went on from there but
after I got off the phone of course I
did a lot of apologizing so it's all
good but I'm still happy to be here
tonight did anybody see yesterday in the
USA Today the article okay I'm the only
one who read you we all read New York
Times raw but good well some of us read
USA Today there's a great article
yesterday and it says animations ship
has come in that was the headline and
it's a great article if you get a chance
find somebody who like me who reads USA
Today and go get a copy it's a great
article and animation ship has indeed
come in so let's let's just dive into
this thing shall we Andrews is a
California native he actually planned on
joining the Marine Corps after high
school way to go but attended Cal arts
instead after beginning an internship at
Disney he worked as a storyboard artist
on several films at Pixar studios he
wrote and directed a short film one-man
band which earned him an academy award
nomination for Animated Short subject
he also directed the short film violet
in 2012 he made his feature directorial
debut with brave and also served as
co-writer and second unit director on
the live action movie John Carter please
welcome Mark Andrews
Kenny chair first chair Oh work whoo
hello check check yeah tears ready very
nice I have my question so I'll be
reading so forgive me mark uh how are
you by the way fine congratulations
thank you you're excited thank you yes
very excited I hope so oh so we're
excited for you and also I apologize
Brenda Chapman your co-director could
not be here tonight she's not feeling
well she got ill at the BAFTAs I guess
or something I guess so what have sounds
going right on it's a songs going around
and England is are you on I believe so
can you hear me yes thank you sir all
right uh I'm gonna dive in and ask some
questions what do you think do it all
right all right I'm ready third degree
all right brave is the first film from
Pixar with a female protagonist yeah did
this have any effect on your creative
decisions as you approach the story ah
no love it and it and it shouldn't
really you know as a storyteller when
we're making these characters I mean and
all the Pixar films we have you know an
old man we have a boy scout we have a
bug we have a fish we have a superhero
we have a car we have a robot we have
toys who gives a crap what exactly they
are you know what really matters is the
type of character that they are and and
we grow the characters from the ground
up you know we plant the seed of an idea
of what's required I'll the story of how
do we give this character this great
path that they have to grow on they
start from one place and to the other
you know we knew this character it had
to be independent and they had to be
strong-willed because they're there
they're transforming out of out of
adolescence into adulthood you know in a
film that's all about change and
transformation and
has magic elements it all ties in
together so you wanted that on top of
that you put it in the Middle Ages and
if it was about a prince big deal
princess get to do what they want
there's no stake sale you know I want to
marry the farmer's daughter fine but
have them have a queen on the side all
right you know so to have her dilemma
her choices then she has to be a female
and in that time you know in that age
and that part of the story comes out of
was inspired by Brenda's own
relationship with her daughter who at
the time Emma who was 6 or thereabouts--
and was this very independent fiery you
know strong-willed difficult at times
you know little girl and Brenda kind of
flash forward in the future and said was
she going to be like as a teenager and
that that kind of idea has a lot of has
a lot of merit and and as a story toe
when you get something that's that you
know kind of universal and relatable
it's like whoa that's that's really good
right that would make a great story now
let's set it where a Scotland done you
know and and we're off and running well
that and that brings up a good point too
I mean it was set in Scotland and you
use several Scottish actors and you know
for the voice cast as well as a Scottish
composer yeah to write the score I'm
assuming this was an important part you
know getting the characters and getting
the music right and to give that
authentic feel is that something you
were conscious about yeah I mean we go
see movies so that we can be you know a
young Scottish lasses in the highlands
you know fighting against magic and and
the social views at the time we go see
movies so we can be a nurse in world war
one you know treating amputees and
falling in love I do we go to see movies
so we can be warlords in space operatic
adventures or the you know the marine
charging up the hill you
we go to escape we go to be entertained
so we have to create worlds that are
authentic you know that that have
something that we don't have in our
normal everyday lives so to get that
authentic character of Scotland not only
do we have to go there and really be in
it didn't bring back all those kind of
details but cast it with Scottish folks
it wasn't necessarily a requirement it
just kind of turned out that way you
know Brenda loved our composure a
Patrick Doyle since he made his debut
with Henry 5 I did too he just happens
to be Scottish you know which was great
and when I sat down with him to do the
music i say i didn't want wall-to-wall
bagpipes if I hear a bagpipe I'm gonna
hit you in the face and he's all right
all right I see what you're talking
about all right let's did and and if we
have some bagpipes in the score so he's
fine we worked it out but what I didn't
want is I didn't want that caricature of
Scotland that's just backpacks I wanted
an ancient Scotland you know I wanted an
old feel so he really got into that and
he knew those melodies kind of from
those times and and and going deep into
the celtic roots and he dug up old
instruments and stuff and liars and
things like that that they used back
then and flutes and whistles and stuff
and that's and that's was the root of
the music wow that that's that's really
awesome to hear deep yeah yeah I know I
love that I love that so let me ask you
are you a parent I am okay and you
talked about you know there was an
influence on Brenda from her daughter as
a parent do you have experiences that
influence the writing and directing of
this movie or any other yeah there's
lots I mean being a parent and I have a
daughter and three sons just as it turns
out does Fergus and the movie
I wasn't planned but being the dad and
I'm kind of you know at my house I'm a
lot like Ferguson my wife is kind of
like the queen she actually runs the
house tells me what to do when I just
laugh and make jokes at parties and all
that kind of stuff and get angry every
once in a while the kids dads but I mean
as a parent the thing that I was
noticing with my wife of my daughter's
relationship where the very things that
were going on in in this story that I
could I could see and I could pull from
I mean they're always telling each other
just listen to me just listen if you
just see my side of it so that's that's
in there and it's very relatable but the
other thing is a in as a watching being
a parent of a parent and child
relationship it's them growing up you
know that they're they're not you're a
kid anymore they're turning into an
adult and that's we're becoming their
equals and one thing that I do with my
kids I play with them all the time I
just come home from work and I'll lie
down on the floor I'm all wrestling time
which it just means dog pile up anytime
but when we're playing like that or
we're playing with LEGOs or action
figures it's no longer a parent-child
relationship it's a person in personal
relationship and they get to know me as
me and I get to know them as them and
that's really special and that's
something that I put directly into the
movie with with to to break down that
kind of hierarchy barrier it's play play
is the great equalizer we're no longer
boss and whatnot you just come down and
it's just just playing and you see the
truth in the person so that whole moment
when they're in the river if anybody has
seen the movie if you haven't please
rush out and see it remember to vote
that was all based on play and all the
plane moments with the triplets and
everything all that stuff with Fergus
playing with merit at the beginning and
teaching oh shoot all that stuff was
kind of from my experiences and I
remembered there's a one-line my
daughter who's my oldest was having
problems with her brothers and I to me
when I came on the scene they hadn't
done anything I'm a boy's gotta Maeve
reprimand reprimand reprimand reprimand
she's all but it was them I'm all go to
your room she's all my brothers get away
with murder and I can't get away with
anything and I'm all oh that's going
into movie so I took that right into
work that day and dropped it right in
the script and it's there yeah my sister
used to slap her arm and scream Rob Wow
and then my dad would come after me I
tricked my brother's my sister's
diabolical you'd be like bye I'm the
oldest and I got two brothers and I
would just make I would get them so
riled up so that they were cursing just
as my mom was walking by and they're all
do more goodnight you all of a sudden
they're off getting their mouths washed
out myself I've never never had that
experience played sir yes sir well
played um alright let me let me are good
on time I just want to ask a couple more
brave what it is would it have been as
effective as a live-action film had it
been made that way oh that's an
interesting question um I don't know
maybe I think I think when we're
watching an animated film there is more
of a acceptance of it because it's not
something that we've seen every day that
it's it's characterized it specialized
when we look at these characters we go
oh yeah she's trouble with all that hair
in the way she's walking she's troubled
that guy's big you know to get those
same reactions instantaneously out of
live-action film you have to do a lot of
work you know we're automatically sizing
up you know well I do you know Tom
Cruise or Brad Pitt comes I'm oh yeah I
could be that that's not really getting
into the film you know but when the
three Lords son show up you're all doof
doof ER and even more stupid and and
you're there you know you're there with
Meredith so I think there's a much more
and it's been going on for centuries i
mean the caveman painting in the caves
you know illustration
has been such a direct connection to our
emotions and as symbols that it's come
up and it's very complicated now but I
mean through painters you know all the
way up to now and animation is this film
medium I think there's just a quicker
emotional core to an illustration we're
more forgiving of it I think what we're
trying to say then live action and live
action you have to do a lot more work
okay that's great uh last question oh no
last question last question how
important was it to try and keep a
balance of humor with the with the
conflict in the mother-daughter
relationship uh huge that was one of the
central problems that we were having and
crafting the story was making meriden
not just a bratty teen and making
Eleanor not a mommy dearest meaning you
know we would either have merit as being
him and we love mom well we can't have
that okay let's go the other way oh now
moms being a band merit is really sweet
well that does it so yeah having that
balance so we understand where they're
coming from was kind of pivotal for
understanding the relationship that
they're both well-intentioned you know
so there's that whole idea of the scene
that came up that were separate scenes
at first where they're talking to each
other without talking to each other and
we do it through the editorial you know
process the cutting where they're saying
what they really want to say to each
other you know just listen but they're
not in the same room together those were
actual seems that they had that were
separate that separate didn't work but
as soon as you cut them together you go
I get it and then the the cherry on top
of that to really make it work was have
the scene right after that when they are
alone together and they can say what
they want to say and they didn't and and
they let it go and that's real and I
remember we were in a story sessions
great storytelling thank you thank you
we were in a story session and this was
one of the problem and we're all yelling
at each other and say if you've never
been a story room it's fabulous it's
trial by fire it's forging it's Coney
and it's forging steel it's a love
but we're all yelling at each other and
you know throwing things that's great
and one of my storyboard artists goes it
doesn't work it just doesn't this whole
concept doesn't work if they just talk
to each other than the movies over and
I'd oh you're right and it's shut the
room up and I'm all what if we do just
that and they're all wood and then that
idea came up I'm oh let's have him talk
to each other but not and they're all
and they all saw it instantaneously and
you know you know something's a jam or
something's really working when 11
people are in the room going and I pitch
it and they're all yeah yeah yeah I'm
all Kate me I'll go draw it let's go I
thought it was a fabulous way thank
that's do I thought it was wonderful
Mark Andrews everybody grave we're
moving onto ParaNorman now a wonderful
wonderful film I saw it with my kids in
the theater just loved it so let me tell
you about the directors shall I all
right sam fell director sam was born in
the UK graduated from university with a
degree in fine arts he worked as a
director and animator in various
production companies including artem
animations where he was a key animator
on the academy award nominated short
film wats pig he shared directing credit
on flushed away and the tale of
despereaux god I was Despero I even
rehearsed that it's the ex
public school what are you gonna do all
right and also chris butler his
co-director and also writer Chris was
born in merseyside England and has
worked in various capacities on animated
features including character design
storyboard artist and head of story he
spent more than ten years writing the
original script for ParaNorman which was
partly inspired by his grandmother who
told him she was going to quote watch
over him oh right congratulations and
welcome very exciting very good stuff I
had one of those stick figures with the
face did you know that they had those
out yeah Norman yeah yeah I had why
don't I know about this it was a it was
Norman's face on a stick if you got one
of these I don't look i bum a bunch of
them like I just scream can someone saw
this out serious one thing I've learned
is you got to grab the stuff yes go all
right you know cuz there comes it's gone
look it's suddenly going you see all
this cool stuff and we made the film and
I'm more why Sir I've been through a few
films now I had to I had to put it in
front of my face and do that for about
two weeks after we saw have to put my
son to bed oh cuz he enjoyed hearing he
really loved the movie I really really
love that yeah um alright let's dive in
with some some questions so we can get
to talking about things here um you said
uh that was whose grandmother was it i'm
sorry it's my crabs up yeah my dead
grandmother yeah yes sorry my apologies
well we're really that's what was the
inspiration for watching over we knew
that yeah uh and she was the inspiration
for ParaNorman correct there are a few
things that were an inspiration to
paranorman i like grandma nana she was
she was one of them and she did she I
think what was great about her was that
she introduced me to the concept of
death at an early age sounds morbid when
I say
but yeah it was nice she said when i'm
gone i'm gonna stick around to watch
over you at the time I didn't think
haunting right but other people have
said that since then and I think oh yeah
but but but she is a lot I think that's
a common fear I think a lot of us fear
that our dead relatives are watching us
masturbate just me you're on your own
there oh ok started that we're talking
about my grandmother Nana I'm sorry
sorry Nana she be ranked oh she's gonna
be around your ass tonight over um ok
letlive let's let's talk about you too
and the amazing work you've done in the
hard work you've done on a project like
this how and I know you probably get
this all the time how do you divide your
duties we you know we didn't divvy it up
you know and it can you know film can
get very schizophrenic with two
directors and that's like a bomb thing
you know so I mean obviously Chris had
been with it for a long time you know
like you've been developing it over
years and years and so it's very close
to him and I came like obviously late eh
i think was just to talk you know and my
i could already tell from meeting chris
and looking that the stuff had done that
he'd like the same kind of things i did
so you know what i mean and i think
that's what else you know it's the best
relationship sometimes you just we just
sat down and we talked about how would
you like that you like you know William
egg with Sony I love with limo Gaston do
you like you know John Brian you know we
like so many of the same things though
we were just out to celebrate the stuff
we loved you know so it was that a
shorthand to begin yeah yeah yeah and we
spent like the first year we just spent
together we were like like man we're
like a married couple you know just like
water it's over now
correctly I thought we might go I
thought we might be a chance to carry on
but you know it's done i think i think
part of it as well was the when Sam came
in he looked there were several projects
that were going on in development but I
think because this so specifically
references definite things you know it's
definitely referencing the 80s we always
talk about it is John Carpenter meets
John Hughes yes and all that was in his
grip that's a great help you know I mean
though that was always intentional so I
think once once he saw what I was doing
if he if you know those references then
you know what it is it wasn't like we
were ever struggling to find out what
the movie was about you know so it
actually gave us the opportunity to sit
down in a room and discuss the aesthetic
more than you know what it was about
yeah i mean i'd been headed i think i'd
been heading to this project since like
1972 when I saw my first Ray Harryhausen
movie you know like I just I've just
been into monster stuff forever and for
some reason ec comics were widely
available in the isle of sheppey and Ken
when I was growing up in the 70s you
know like all of this kind of American
pop culture was coming to Britain you
know at that time and like we were just
kind of immersed in you know the whole
wave of Spielberg movies and special
waste beer works career took off and
like movies like ET you know Tony's yeah
cause there's so much and you know so
coming to this it's like it's not alien
to us from the UK you know like for me
it was with her specific horror films oh
yeah that's fine yeah yeah and I watched
night of the living dead when I think I
was eight that's terrifying we rolling I
thought it's black and white how bad
could it be
and then there was the part where in the
base field is eating her mother in the
basement and that stuck with me I saw
Salem's Lot and it was in black and
white but it might have been my cheap TV
yeah yeah you can catch same color
didn't put it I found it to be
terrifying yeah yeah yeahs at very young
age but you like that you know i think
you want to be scared you know like when
you're growing up and I always remember
that you know you would wait on my
parents gone to bed and then sneak back
down and likes click on the TV and there
be some late-night Dracula or something
and it would be really scary this
Siddalee yeah yeah you want to go to
this unknown place that your parents
don't want you to go to you just do and
this was definitely video nasties as we
called them yeah I suppose this was
zombie movie so it was it was nice of a
living dead uh cat cannibal holocaust
you could get one now really I don't go
to knock Sorry Sorry like the VHS
changed lamb life didn't you could eat
it you could see like driller killer
without trying to get into the movie
theater you know cuz it was out on VHS
in the tray your sisters older boyfriend
left it lying around the angle you could
just pop in I must interject though in
that driller killer did not influence
and family miss a family movie know some
of the garish lighting yeah yeah there
to be honest it was like you know
neither living dead dawn of the dead day
the dad any movie with the word dead in
it apparently all the zombie movies to
me what it came down to was that in
wanting to make a zombie movie for kids
I looked all the good zombie movies and
they're all social commentary they all
you zombies as a metaphor and that was
the idea really behind this was what
would the social commentary be and it
turned out to be bullying so there is
see I made it highbrow now that's good I
like this Holden sound a bit clunky ya
know but this is good this is we will
this is good i want to hear where you're
you're coming from i want to know the
thought process and and the things that
motivated you inspired you change things
in the course of making it you know i
mean it is a process yeah so that is i
love hearing that stuff I'm sure
everybody else does too um
well I got your on a tactical mood let
me ask you some technical questions here
was there any pressure to make the film
with computer or cell animation as
opposed to stop motion is there any
pressure no I mean it came from like you
know like that Chris was already there
Coraline is at home you know like wet
its outstanding you know I standing I
mean you're basically Travis night the
guy that set the studio there and all
the people there they love stop motion
may just another you know and they're
not like they're not purus they don't
want to just keep it old fashioned and
make it museum piece I want we were
adding a lot of new technology we used a
lot of computers in there and a lot more
final scene with the the tree and though
yeah she is a puppet that's what we
always wanted to do it was always not
pure it Travis always causes Luddites
you've embraced the loom in that we will
use whatever technology is available to
us to make sure that what you see on the
screen looks the best that it can we we
try and make sure that it you know at
its heart is stop motion so almost every
shot I think starts with a puppet so the
aggie was a physical puppet norman was a
puppet so the animator onset can get
that physical relationship between them
under lights but then on top of that we
have 2d animation we have CG animation
she had a CG dress and it wasn't that we
were trying to take shortcuts it was
just that we wanted to make her look
like something that you've never seen
before I wanted when people saw Aggie to
think I don't know how they did that as
opposed to I don't know why they did
then yeah I love it I mean that it to me
it speaks to craftsmanship yeah you know
that's what it speaks that's what I feel
like it is and it's also do would you
consider this your signature on
animation as far as the way it looks you
know I think we made our own look you
know I we will just move yeah we were
away like when we first met we were like
oh my god you know we're making a stop
motion we're in the world of horror you
know there's I mean there's a very
well-known director out here today today
you know does great horror stop-motion
have no idea who talk
well you know it's just like you know
there's a macys film took the pretty
good yeah but we just sit you know you
don't go there you know or like we
really wanted to create our own
signature and feelings right mood and I
think like drawing from like the 80s
movies gave us our own flavor and also
like the just in terms of the color and
lighting we wanted to be really punching
it with a color and we were looking at
like Italian horror movies like in a
fortune Barbra and stuff so yeah we
worked through every single aspect of
the production to really make it unique
thing in like our own well mission
accomplished gentleman cuz it's an
outstanding film paranorman thank you
chris butler and sam fell everyone
thanks guys let's keep it rolling know
you guys have fun I love hearing this
stuff it's so cool okay next up is the
Pirates band of misfits am i right they
gave me no running order i'm guessing
let's hope it's pirates Peter Lord is
the director and producer born in
Bristol England Peter Lord formed
aardman animations with David Roxton and
it was a low-budget studio for producing
shorts and trailers Nick Park joined the
company in the late 80s Ottoman produced
such oscar-nominated and oscar-winning
shorts as creature comforts a grand day
out the wrong trousers yeah go ahead let
it flow it deserves it a close shave and
a matter of loaf and death as well as
wallace and gromit in the curse of where
rabbit which in 2005 won the Oscar for
animated feature film so that was lord
has also been nominated for animated
short film Adam and wats pig
congratulations thank you that's
outstanding and what a one
full film what a wonderful phone you
must be very proud i'm very proud you
social and had a lot of fun making it of
course good good well it's been 12 years
since chicken run since you're since
you've directed yes why did you decide
to return to directing after producing
for so many years I didn't I didn't ever
really want to produce to be honest it
just happened to me I know is so easy if
you're not if you're not watching
carefully it just happens to you and I
never really know I didn't want to you
know but I felt it was necessary sure
actually and and then I started to
realize if I didn't put my hands up
that's quick I was gonna I was gonna be
a producer for evermore which was just a
terrible fate so um this project came
along and I grabbed him oh I'm glad you
did I'm really glad you did of the five
pirate books that were out there why did
you decide to film this one uh we didn't
we didn't take the books very seriously
I mean as raw material world best left
and that's rubbish it's not true the
fact is that the writer of the books
wrote the screenplay so that's a
fantastic question to be absolutely and
we he'd written to at the time I think
so we bought the rights to to and
started to evolving the first one and
with him and it was great introduction
you know it was very mischievous it was
such a funny idea I just I just I read
this book people often developed and
turn books into movies it's a very
common thing but I never it their range
to me before really i've been very
scornful vin thought it was a lazy thing
to do and you should come up with a new
idea and then them then I found this
book on it in a meeting and I just
thought i read it and i thought it was
the funniest thing i've ever read pretty
well so i couldn't resist it basically
i'll standing where are there any other
books in this series that you would like
to think i would for so he's written
he's written the pirates in adventure
it's called in english try in England
and it's good we speak American here
it's called the Pirates in an adventure
with scientists okay and and I think
that's a very nice joke because it's a
and I think the studio over here I'll do
it was to English and joke cuz what why
it's a joke is because it's all about
disappointment actually it's a big like
it's like it's like the Pirates it was
scientists well who wants to see that so
that was his joke and that's the rain
English joke and but that but but you
know probably the studio ver hear
something that was maybe was scared the
audience too much running so he's also
written the Pirates in adventure with
way lean the pirate adventure with
romantics and the parish ended of it in
the venture was communists so like eat
so yeah is I think I think fast and
loose is what he's playing with it with
with history tastic that's fantastic um
Hugh Grant not normally associated with
you know this type of work or or voice
work I guess how'd you decide on him to
play your captain yeah that was it was
very interesting because I wanted him
for for his close-up comedy really me
then because a lot really a lot of the
movie is some comedy dialogue and that
was the big attraction to me and yes I
wanted a you know a star with a big
leading man that helps with the movie
and so we we approached him and the
script was great Hugh Grant always has
been saying for the past 10 years he
doesn't want to act anymore which is he
has to be dragged out out of retirement
or dragged off the golf course to come
and to come and act isn't it really
wants to but he was totally sold on the
script so that was great but then but
then initially it was quite hard work
and I'm sure he wouldn't mind me saying
so for actually for both of us because
he does his stick as this fabulous
close-up come with either the Rays of
the eyebrows the hesitation all that
stuff
so well and the start of the production
I wanted to do a lot of big chested
roaring and stuff like that and and be
big and show off and he didn't like it
at all I really didn't want to do that
and so I wish we hadn't started there
that then we got onto the more intimate
stuff but comedy stuff and he got really
comes to with him by the end he was
showing off really fine but yeah that is
true too when you start the process when
you the first day in the studio it's a
discovery a little bit isn't it for the
actor and for the director and the
producers and everybody yes I mean I
don't know about the other the other
directors here but we almost never got
the actors together and it's just it's a
weird thing about animation I don't
think it's a good thing I'm not proud of
it I think in fact I think it's stupid
actually but I think you know and so
it's difficult because there's no
there's no chemistry in the room yeah
you're doing them all separately and as
soon as you do get two together so we
had Hugh Grant together with David tent
and with imelda staunton as soon as
they're together it's so easy because I
just play the scene together you know
but if you don't do that then you're
trying to imagine the scene and you and
you assemble it like a sort of
Frankenstein's monster but but
ultimately successfully I'm sure but
it's a hard way to work so difficult for
him he comes in off the street that's
not here there's nothing to see there's
no costume no ship you know we're in
studio and dumb and we do all we can we
bring a puppet in we show him the story
real but it's hard to get that simple
human warmth going and also when you
come in you know as a voice actor you
come in I've come in with an idea in my
head and what the character should be or
what it could be yeah and a lot of times
I'll just do it and hope it sticks has
that ever happened when an actress come
in and said how about this and they
throw something in your like that's so
far off the mark what do you do in
situations like that we had
well the treasure they are turns out
sensitive they are some Pig you just say
that is rubbish now please please don't
do that ever again that's hands
something and then sometimes you record
them for a whole session knowing you'll
never use it because you don't want to
offend them to most but that sounds very
English yeah that sounds very English is
values x rays I must say we work with
Jeremy Piven you know he was as the
villain and by the way that itself is
Right English show because in Britain we
are really tired of all our great actors
always being the villain you know you
know you see all these American movies
and the bad guys Jeremy Irons or
something and so um so it was our
private joke to to have the bad guy
played by an American well well done
well done well done oh I better ask a
technical question yeah I said it will
you know what they said this was yeah
there's good through aardman am I saying
that right argument yump okay through
aardman you know they're best known for
stop-motion flushed away Arthur
Christmas they were made computer yeah
animation yeah why did you decide to
make pirates stop motion um I think we
love stop-motion best like there's these
guys that we hear me they go Abby it's
it's what we've always always done the
mean I've done it for a very long time
since I was a high school I've been
doing it and we've built around us a
team of people who are brilliant at it
and love doing it just love doing it and
as I says though as they were saying
it's a it's a very great environment to
work in with all respect to other
important studios say in the Bay Area
the dude that do sees you who do you
know some quite successful films
actually but the fact is and you know
we've met with posting some of the
publicity about the studio there and it
seems a pretty crazy place to work with
but that's because they work is so dull
because
what they're doing all day sitting at
computer though right but but in our
world we're walking around we're working
with paint and and iron and and and
cameras and lights and it and toys the
most amazing amazing toys in the world
you know it's the lovely lovely
environment I mean when we have studio
open days you know people just die for
it because it's it's because it's just a
big old big old barn like you know like
this boat and with black curtains and
you pull aside the black curtain and
inside it's just some beautiful
miniature set so it's a very very
exciting and one of the environment to
live in having said all that mean though
we done cg films and and I it tomorrow I
think in certain stories are much much
more appropriate to cg I think stop
motion stopped frame we've made it we
make we've made quite a big film in the
Paris but it is kind of it's a bit more
sort of chamber orchestra thing I think
a more intimate scale is appropriate
fantastic well you've made a winner here
and congratulations Peter Lord everyone
awesome next up wreck-it Ralph
pretty great rich Moore director and
story rich Moore studied animation at
California Institute of the Arts he
wrote and designed the short film
technological threat and was the
sequence director for the simpsons movie
simpsons movie i said it wrong i say
like my son says it he has won Emmys for
his work on Futurama and the simpsons
and he is pretty awesome congratulations
thank on this wonderful make any
particular video game inspire wreck-it
Ralph oh boy there's a lot I love well
we drew a lot from our past you know
that you would be amazed that at an
animation studio there's a lot of people
who like video games you wouldn't i find
that was ablaze I interesting um yeah um
definitely Donkey Kong 100 I've pac-man
you know just those old you know games
from the 80s I felt like wreck-it Ralph
had a donkey kong little bit i mean
other than they don't like to say too
much let's just kind of keep that on the
deal ok so the 90s you know almost
everything released by disney features
some sort of musical number was ever any
thought to maybe making wreck-it Ralph a
musical well never a full-blown musical
but there was a period in time where
there where the character King candy
who's the the alan tudyk full voice to
rip some great voice actors yeah they're
wonderful cats very very lucky to work
at a great the cast rehab but there was
a point where we did write a song for
King candy and where he was describing
the world that they lived in and it it's
not a very good story but they but they
did you Helen did not Alan did not
record it but Bob
lopez from Book of Mormon wrote the song
he and his wife Kristen and they did a
temp of it and it was describing how
they solved any dispute in sugar rush
that they raced for everything was of it
was kind of a like a Mary Poppins
Sherman Brothers esque you know type the
song didn't work so so it's not in the
movie thank you for trying yeah we tried
that's that's our process you know it's
like we you got me try lots of stuff we
throw it against the wall and that the
sticks you know stays in the movie and
it's an interesting it's a very organic
process of making films like this yes as
you know yes yes this particular movie
some there been some recent animated
features how to train your dragon
ratatouille that have had complicated
production histories did record Ralph
move smoothly through the whole process
or you know where their major changes
made along the way well there had been
for for many years at the studio I mean
going back like 15 to 18 years I'm not
quite sure what the history was but
there was a desire to make an animated
film about the life of video game
characters so when I came in to the
studio in 2008 as a director and
discovered you know that they had just
put it on the shelf again about six
months prior in a different incarnation
I thought well that's you know I kind of
like that that seems you know I'm like
video games that seems like a really
good rich world you know to set
something a story in so without kind of
going back to the material that had been
done before I just started what that
idea of you know the life of video game
characters what's that's what is that
like so what's fascinated and and when
you talk about video games you talk
about that the the real game characters
that you were able to bring in yes
zangief Qbert great sankey yeah there's
a great Zangief and you were able to
work them into your film
did that I'm assuming that helped and
enhanced oh absolutely um from the very
beginning I felt that it was to do a
movie like this it was necessary to have
real characters from games in it just to
give it a legitimacy and kind of a
feeling of authenticity to that world so
we we began in the beginning of
developing the story since we couldn't
really go to those companies so early on
and and ask can we have permission to
use your characters in a way we have no
idea that we're going to use them you
know because we're still trying to
figure out you know the story ourselves
so for about the first year of
developing the story I said to the story
crew let's just pretend like we have
full rights to anyone we want you know
that's not I like let's not limit
ourselves and say well we don't want to
use Bowser because we probably can't get
them so just you know if they're
appropriate for the scene put them in
and and then we'll we'll go about you
know someday we'll cry you know we'll
get to that bridge will cross it then
you know so we just approached it as if
you know the world was you know ours to
pick from I think that's a right right
of approaching I really do and and you
probably did you get much friction from
people no not really I mean we we Clark
Spencer who's my producer and I we
decided you know rather than let's try
and make relationships with these with
these companies rather than sending
phalanx of Disney lawyers out to meet
Nintendo's lawyers on the battlefield
and let them fight to the death and the
last one Israel I think we've got our
next movie right phalanx of Disney
lawyers yeah I always wanted to stand on
a stage and say phalanx in front of
failing
Peter Lourdes owed he's so jealous right
he could have turned that so well with
that accident good oh yeah yeah
absolutely could well yeah but you have
a unique I'll go ahead and finish please
I can't remember I'm so swept up by the
work bae lengths i was helping you good
yeah well you have you have wonderful
perspective on a lot of things in your
career you've directed over a dozen
episodes of Simpsons futurama TV
animation film animation how would you
compare well um I mean I other than some
of the nuts and bolts mean right and
while i would say on the simpsons TV
directing from the first day you're
behind basically you know it's like okay
we start this joke today where is it you
know it's like aren't you done yet you
know it's it's really a sprint it's a
mad dash you know to to get this thing
finished you know to hit these deadlines
and it really needs to be good you know
the jokes need to play the emotion needs
to be there so it was really for a young
animation director it was a great trial
by fire of you know taking a script
realizing it into a show you know and
getting it done on time but making it
the best it could be you know and waking
and working with heroes like Matt
graining and Jim Brooks you know and Sam
Simon on The Simpsons if it was just the
best education that one could get in
character based animated comedy you know
so so that was great and but it's a very
fast schedule you know and a movie
schedule is it's it's much longer you
know they need to be pieces that stand
the test of time you know and they're
there needs to be more depth to them and
the characters are they need to take a
journey and grow they have to have an
arc they it's not like a TV show where
they start
here at square one they take a little
journey something happens and they go
and right back at square one so they can
do it next week all over again so but so
the and the apparatus is different too
but the ultimate job of telling an
emotional story with characters that you
care about and setting that all in a
world that's fantastic but but
believable that feels like our world I
would say the simpsons in wreck-it Ralph
are very much the same thing the job is
the same interesting do you ever are you
ever satisfied do you ever get to god no
yeah i do not know place where you're
like it's ready for the world or do you
just get to a place where take it you
know how do i there John Lasseter says
we don't what is it we don't we don't
release these films uh I can't remember
Lisa but it was really good it was
really really good um mark andrews could
you we released them thank you I
wondered about that I won't know about
that yeah how are you failing
well that's a rich more everyone
congratulations on record route finally
tonight we have a wonderful wonderful
film and a wonderful director Frankie
Duany there's a long time coming but
it's here and of course the director Tim
Burton director producer and original
idea for Frankenweenie you probably know
everything already but I'll throw some
stuff out there Tim Burton was born in
Burbank California he began drawing at
an early age he studied animation at Cal
arts and worked Disney on the Animated
Feature the Fox and the hound he
directed two short films for the studio
stop motion vincent and the live-action
Frankenweenie before directing his first
feature pee-wee's big adventure which I
remember seeing in the theater and
loving the stars are big and bright deep
in the heart of texas love them along
with his many live-action features he's
produced and wrote the story for a
nightmare before christmas he produced
James and the Giant Peach he produced
and directed and created the character
for Tim Burton's Corpse Bride which
earned him an Oscar nomination for
Animated Feature and produced nine his
credits are numerous you if you've ever
watched a movie you've probably seen a
Tim Burton movie uh I'm sorry looks like
you're hurt and I just thought it looked
cool it does this or an iPad that's that
I go with that any day over the eyepatch
I like it congratulations I mean it's so
awesome ok no I'm not gonna do it a
third time this was another
second uh well that's what yeah let me
ask you how closely to the original
Frankenweenie I mean how much did you
model the original to this the short to
this let me just went back to the
drawings after and not you know many
years in looking at them and you know
after working on a couple of stop
motions it just felt like a more pure
version of it and there was something
about you know the the Frankenstein
story inanimate objects coming back to
life which you know fits the medium very
well and you know got to explore Burbank
again without actually going there which
was nice I love Burbank were you able to
do anything with this feature-length
Frankenweenie that you weren't able to
do with the short other than maybe
expand the story or yeah because of such
a memory pieces is it was fun to kind of
go back and you know really go back and
like you know loving another monster
movies putting that kind of instead of
the Frankenstein structure over the
house of Frankenstein or like you and
abbott and costello meet frankenstein
where they threw it a bunch of other
monsters and and you know remembering
the kids that i went to school with like
you know I knew several the weird girls
that were and then and the teachers the
kind of scary teachers that you didn't
know what they were talking about and
you know and and you know I remember
like when we built the classroom and
seeing it for the first time I got a
really ill feeling so I knew we got that
accurately and so yeah I mean it was it
was fun to really just go back and
explore and expand upon those memories
absolutely at what point in the film's
development did you decide to convert it
to 3d well I was always the intention I
mean the thing that you know the people
that worked on stop motion no is it such
a tactile I mean you know being on a set
and seeing the characters and feeling it
I think it its it's you feel the artists
work you know you see the textures
better you feel like what it's actually
like to be on a stop-motion set so the
idea of you know the opportunity of
doing black and white and 3d was just
something special to me did you get any
resistance on the black and white
no I mean they're used to well they're
not quite used to me but you know I
remember you know back in the good old
days it was it like a nightmare I mean
they remember having like extreme like
you want to have a main character that
has no eyes you know that's like they're
always used to some kind of thing that's
a no they were they were cool about it I
think they understood the fact that it
was you know part of the story and for
me it helped with the emotion of it and
and you know like i said the opportunity
of black and white and 3d just felt
special right right when you started at
Walt Disney you were quoted as saying
animation was a dead medium how do you
feel now well as you can see it's this I
mean those were the dark days they were
no that's where you're supposed to like
I was the worst Disney animator I mean
that's why I was lucky that they I was
so bad that especially the drawing of
foxes I mean it this is like roadkill
yeah so I i was i was lucky in some ways
the dark days kind of got me you know
into being able to sit in a room for a
couple of years and just draw whatever I
wanted to do and so in some ways it was
it was a really special time for me yeah
I imagined it would be Frankenweenie
it's the first feature that you've
directed since big fish that didn't
involve Johnny Depp at all did you ever
consider Johnny for anything in this for
anything now you did he does do good
barking sounds but no all except for two
of your features have been scored by
Danny Elfman do you see the role of
music and animated films is different
than live action films in any way no I
mean you know my relationship with him
is always about you know it's like
another character and I think
when you're you know he likes the same
kind of stuff I do so he gets the horror
movie idea gets the emotion of the story
so you know always treat him is like
another character and how closely in
Frankenweenie were you involved with the
designing of the sets and the characters
and well I mean I was the whole goal was
to kind of go back to you know the
original drawings i did for you know the
live action which is obviously it's a
different thing so you know it was it
was trying to get back to the that kind
of the purity of those things and and
and actually more of the memory of
Burbank I shot the first one in pasadena
but the idea of getting like it's just
the feeling of like the classroom in the
school and the city hall and it like I
said I I knew we were getting there when
I'd get this sort of queasy feeling it
you know and and then kind of shocked
memory of it so you know we had a fairly
smallish crew but it but but but you
know and it was because a lot of the
crew was British or Bulgarian and all
sorts of other places to try and
describe Burbank to them they do you
think I was talking about another planet
somehow but we got there that's also um
well will you stay up here and we'll
bring up bring everybody back up we'll
just do a group thing if that's all
right a group hug all right okay let's
bring the rest of the directors back up
what do you say um I've got questions
know that you can refresh it every time
with a new glass and everything like we
got money okay we can do this will be
all right yes we read all your writers
they're very specifically now um okay so
let me just dive in he as good as your
herd and tim this uh I'll throw it out
to you and I'll also throw it out to to
Sam and Chris as well um and Peter why
not i'll throw it out to you as well
in an age of where animated films are
dominated by commute computer animation
films like yours have shown the
stop-motion can still thrive do you
think stop-motion can continue as a tool
and visual effects for live-action films
as well or has that role been
permanently taken over by a commute
computer innovation anybody one jump in
on that I I think it mostly it's going
you know like mostly you'd use computers
of live-action just because it's just
just to kind of combine things right
it's just well yeah I mean I think it
also to on footage I think there's a
there's a bottom line in in Hollywood
you know where if something I mean I
remember many years ago when excuse
Disney they say they were going to stop
making drawn animated films which seemed
like acquainted yeah rash statement
luckily they kind of went and did it but
yet you know I mean they do look at the
medium and then they look at box office
and you know like in the say the case of
Frankenweenie you know it wasn't the
highest-grossing picture of the year and
I do think that they you know it's not
like studio to wish list do let's make a
black and white stop motion animation
you know I mean these guys feel you know
did but I think they you know you hope
it can survive and because i think we
all love it and so it's it's I think it
in itself it will I just stop motion
like this they don't always go on
because people love them people love
making them and people are watching them
there is a hard core audience they're
just lover I think also it enables us to
delve into the shadows maybe a little
bit more it allows us to to go places
that may be bigger budgets wouldn't go
to I think that because we tend to be
smaller budgets we're allowed to maybe
tell slightly different kinds of stories
almost an indie vibe yeah why not but
also kid thing I noticed too is like you
guys we're talking about it's like in
Peter saying like I had my child's class
come to to to see it and the excitement
that they get from singer than the next
day I got you know from these little
kids they just went home and did
stop-motion animated movie
and you know I talk to them the next day
the Indonesian sweatshop but the nimble
little finger I think there's so there's
there is a power to it that I think
hopefully will always be there
absolutely we always described it as
like being like Santa's workshop except
the lsat taller I've got tattoos and
piercings 44 Frankenweenie and
paranorman was there ever any concern
for younger audiences we're now we go oh
that's good I'm not even gonna kill your
boss that was really is something that
we thought about every day yeah actually
the soundtrack can adjust things a lot
you know like surprising what you can do
in music and sound in terms of tipping
it too scary or not too scary computer
animation gives filmmakers the leeway to
choose any virtual look that they want
or any look that they won't from classic
to traditionally drawn animation stereo
or two photo realism what look were you
going for in your films and what
motivated that choice well i was going
for many different styles in wreck-it
Ralph that I wanted each of the
different worlds then Ralph traveled to
to to feel that it was it had its own
art direction to it the devote those
styles of games you know that it
represented so like the commotion of the
House members right like the 8-bit world
a fix-it Felix jr. and the the realism
and the hostility of hero's duty and
then that kind of whimsical charm of
sugar rush you know that that kind of
took knots from Nintendo and children's
games and which was turned out to be
more of a challenge than you would think
because they're there seems to be this
invisible force that wants to make the
movie look all of one piece of one mind
you know and it just it's just something
that happens on its own and and I was
you know
part of my job was to remind designers
and animators and layout artists you
know no these should be very different
you know so it was kind of pushing
against this thing that naturally just
wants to happen you know in trying to
keep each of those worlds very separate
and unique in and of themselves embraer
we were looking at you know this place
actually exists but we didn't want to go
totally photo-real we want to get
capture those textures and the varieties
of the landscape and then in animation
because you can we push it we accentuate
it we plus it there's no standing stone
on this earth that's as big as the ones
that are in brave those things we more
than the freaking pyramids those things
they're massive the calendar stones the
tallest ones like 12 feet tall these
ones were like 60 feet tall and we could
do whatever we wanted and with the
lighting we wanted a very theatrical
lighting so we can really control the
mood of the piece because ultimately
brave is a darker story it's one of the
darkest stories that Pixar has has done
and the Scottish Highlands kind of evoke
that kind of mystery in that dark
foreboding this so we were just trying
to capture that in and and push it well
that's a good point it kind of leads
into a question that I'll throw out to
all of you when you approach your films
is there a challenge or is there a
thought to trying to make a film for
adults and children in the same the same
stroke I guess well I think since I'm an
adult and a child at the same time not
bipolar mind you but that we just make
what we like you know I think that goes
to the superficiality of this medium if
you make it for particular audience you
just screwed the other audience you know
if you make it just for girls you screw
the guys make it for guys its crew to
grow that that we just make something
that I we would want to see and that's
kind of kind of the goal and if we push
it too far in its PG
13 than your dial it back dial it dial
it that day council one guiding you say
shoot phalanx Peter I want to hear
petersons piranha you can turn that fat
links so that is it is better I don't
know what it is it's that accent I don't
that's just my call anybody else yeah
well I throw that out there because you
know a lot a lot of the films are what
you know wonderfully entertaining for
adults and four children and that's not
an easy thing to do I mean that's
skilful writing it's really really
skillful storytelling well I'll throw
another audience um not just this film
but I seem to get a lot of comments from
people saying that dogs really like my
movies and not just this one so it's
like yeah so duly noted it's true it's
true don't like my movies but dogs and
small baby through the roof you're doing
there was like and white baby oh um and
again this is for everybody what were
the inspirations for your films visual
styles did you have any something I mean
we all have inspiration weekly old
episodes of Davey and Goliath no no no
that one yeah yeah yeah we liked Mario
Bava and like some of the Italian horror
okay color sure sure actually for me as
well it was it was scooped we always
thought scooby-doo an episode of
scooby-doo directed by Sam Raimi for
example we just I would work with a
wonderful production designer and he was
like he was so perfect for the job
because he worked on Brazil with terry
gilliam he worked on Princess Bride he'd
worked on hook it's a pirate movie and
and haha but and he worked on the benny
hill show when he was a young man
I it was just perfect fantastic that is
fantastic and and this is for this is a
technical thing but it's one of those
things that I find interesting did your
cast work together or individually and
we talked about that earlier it's a
combination with us we tried for the
kids in particular we try to get them
together and it was exactly for that
spontaneity that you you you've
struggled to find when they record on
their own especially for kids who don't
have as much experience I mean Kodi
smit-mcphee voice Norman and he's a
phenomenal actor the kid who played
Tucker is best taco who played Neal his
best friend had little experience
relatively so to put them together you
got that awkwardness and they stepped on
each other and not physically and but
they started and they stand and we got
all that real stuff that is a gift to an
animator when I started talking to john
c reilly about the playing the character
of Ralph he said well I love the story I
love the script I love the whole idea
but I've I've heard that the way you
make these movies is that the actor goes
into a booth and puts on some headphones
and just kind of acts out into this void
and I don't like that you know that
sounds horrible to me you know I I I
don't think i can give you my best if
I'm if I'm acting that way and I said
well you know the good thing about our
processes were not slaves to it you know
the movies the thing so if it and it
made sense to me what he was saying you
know if I if if this is the first time
the john c reilly and sarah silverman
are appearing in a movie together the
audience wants to hear that chemistry
like Peter was talking about it would be
like we're gonna make Laurel and Hardy
but we're going to shoot each one
separately in digitally put them
together it's like and it just seemed
like that makes sense you know so we
something's resident true and that's
yeah and
and I said you know what that's we can
we can get you and Sarah together we can
get you know I got Jack and Jane
together and and it made the recording
so much better you know the fact that
they could that they could act you know
with one another that they could look
into each others eyes that they could
you know play off of the mood that the
other one was creating I can't imagine
you know trying to getting the same
results by splicing something together
that was done on separate days so we did
and primarily all of our are recording
together but we did have like early days
where where Sarah recorded alone and
those were great sessions to just kind
of find the character you know so by the
time the two of them work together they
were real solid and who they were a
hybrid of the two forums would seem to
be the best of that's because you can
work out some individual character
things and then you bring the team
together and you find that that magic
yeah that sometimes comes through when
you're just riffing or improvising or
what the character would naturally say
absolute anybody else yeah I mean well I
did similar to these I mean mainly with
Martin Short and Katherine with the
parents use it does you get an intimacy
and it does help so it was a mixture of
things and I think the only other
problem is these films take so long it's
like with the kids you know they start
one way in your call oh we need to do a
few more lines I was like okay you know
they're like oh Jesus Christ Cuba d so
you know that's the problem with kid you
know you can't go back and redo lines
but yeah it does help it does it does
help when you can when you can do it you
all have spent so much time on your
movies these are not easy to do these
are not quick turnarounds these are
years and years in the making so for the
final question I just want to throw it
out and have each one of you answer if
you don't mind but what's what's
something that you really want us to
know
tell us something that we we need to
know about your film nothing I mean no I
mean I it to be honest I always love you
know I think we're in a day and age
where everybody knows everything about
everything and and and you know growing
up again seeing like a ray harryhausen
film and not knowing anything about it
you know I a servo miss those days in a
way and you know so you always like hope
just let the film hopefully speak for
itself so okay I'll take that yeah we
made it we didn't make it for that
opening weekend all their first two
weeks we did we made it to last like
years you know like decades we hope so
it should does speak for itself but you
can watch it at least 10 times that's
awesome more they'll say I'm she'll see
more it keeps unfolding itself to yeah
yeah I think this is it's a rich thing
that's why we put so much time into it
and that's why it's worth it because
that people will be watching it in the
future in right absolutely I think for
me it is when I was a kid I think I told
my mom about I was about age six that I
wanted to be a storyboard artist I don't
even know I didn't even know what it was
I don't they at the time but I
definitely wanted to work in animation
as far as back as I can remember clarity
that's that's how I know it's sick isn't
it it's destiny it's good yeah but i
think that's that's actually the point
is that back then it was the dream to
work not just to work in animation but
to be able to tell your own stories and
this project is definitely a personal
one for me and the idea that i could be
sat on this stage with these people at
this point in my life you know if i
think back to when I was five or six it
is pretty amazing and it can be done
that's very special it's very special
and that's a wonderful journey to it's a
wonderful journey well this may be
dangerous to say since a lot of people
from Disney are here but I would do this
job for free you know I cannot um I I
can't believe I get paid to do this you
know if it weren't my job I'd be in my
garage doing this you know right now so
to be able to do this as a job you know
that and make it living at it you know
and is mind-blowing so I couldn't agree
more I've walked off set swear I said I
would pay you to do that job I think for
me being an animation I was always
pissed off that it was seen as a kid's
medium only I grow with the Disney but I
grew up watching the Japanese animation
as well and and and a lot of it and they
could do whatever they want i said well
why don't we have that here in our
country why can't we do whatever story
want and just have it animated and i
think this year with these these films
and so many more that the the envelope
for animation is being pushed and we
keep seeing more risky deep films that
we wouldn't have done ten years ago you
know coming out and I want to be one of
those guys who's pushing it more and
more and more and more because it's not
only just an awesome medium but there's
so many more stories that we can tell
that shouldn't just be shoved under
because it's not suitable for children
you know and and there's a whole realm
out there of stories that have yet to be
told through distinction do you see more
pg-13 r-rated and yeah
well i'm doing a stop-motion animation
r-rated right now is about yeah yeah
sorry Peter um I well I guess making an
animated film is more definition of
deferred pleasure because I mean it's
you're working it's a long long time
before you get to hear the laughs that I
thank you I've really enjoyed you know
he seen or discuss when you do it you
know you do it to entertain and you
finally after five years ago they hear
it see it hear it but audience laughing
that's precious indeed but that being
that being the case though you've got
love making it you've got love doing it
because it is a long time you know and
for me I will say that the the studio
and the people and that team is as
important to me as the film yeah because
matin then being together and the
atmosphere in the place the spirit the
place I was proud of that as I am of the
film we made in the end absolutely it
has to be a family environment around
the scare i would imagine working that
long and that close well ladies and
gentlemen I want to thank you so much
let's give a round of applause to our
nominees congratulations all
congratulations